في مقابله عابره سريعه مع
[موسيقى]
ذكرت لها اسمه قبل قليل اللبنانيه
الفرنسيه وكان لها معرض في المعهد
اول ما وصلت شاركت في الافتتاح لكن لم
اقابلها فقالت لمراسل الجاردين انه حينما
سمعت بالخبر كما لو كان صفحه
فيه في جانبي للقضيه في جانب ما يسمى
بالصوره النمطيه والافكار المسبقه
كانت تلعب دور كبير جدا حتى داخل المعهد
انه هذا انسان سعودي جاء وليس لديه اضافه
معينه وربما انه كان واحد عربي من المغرب
او من بلاد الشام هو الاولى وكذا وكذا لكن
الجانب الثاني ان هناك اصدقاء كثر وزملاء
كثر في الوسط الثقافي الباريسي يعرفوني
جيدا من ايام الدراسه ومنهم ثلاثه واربعه
في المعهد هؤلاء كانهم موقف اخر ربما
شعروا بنوع من السعاده نوع من العداله نوع
من الانصاف انه يكون فيه اكاديمي
يعرفون جيدا في المعهد
الذي
تيقنت منه
ان هذه الصور النمطيه لم تكن تؤثر علي باي
شكل من الاشكال لانني كنت واعيا
بشيء بسيط واضح وهو ان الانجاز هو الذي
سيحكم في النهايه ومن هنا بدات
وسايره اجامل
واستوعب الى الى ان
عملت ما استطيع ان اعمله واعتقد اعتقد انه
في النهايات
ليس بده نخوض في التفاصيل لكن كان هناك
كسبت الرهان بطريقه انسانيه وهذا الذي
يهمني ليس فقط بالانجاز الذي فعلته وانما
على مستوى العلاقات